all right we get the return to Omashu
and uh yeah I I wish I could be more
angry because I know you guys love it
and you find out after dating step if
you want to see that go see go watching
this Dodger critic cuz I really love the
show they keep throwing good episode for
good episode it's another really really
good episode and it is one that really
ties into the story again you got them
returning back to all my shoe it's been
taken over as we saw from the last one
and the King um the king apparently
surrendered right away
which is very bizarre and that the
people went to hiding underground on
these secret passages and they
introduced this philosophy at the end I
I think it's the philosophy of King is
what they were saying which is the
philosophy of change uh I think that was
it might have been Jean but I don't know
that one uh but what I like about it you
hear hurt hairdryer by the way that's my
wife but what I like about this show is
that it's obviously popular at the time
is being made is probably growing in
popularity they obviously they had a
strong first season but what I like is
that they're introducing ideas and
philosophies that not only are pretty
complex for kids but they're not even
like American philosophies which is
wonderful it's expanding different
outlooks and different thoughts and
techniques and teachings and half these
kids could go up to their parents and be
like you know what are the levels of
Jing well what's the book of Ching and
oh I don't know let's look it up yeah or
make Mason parents would know but I
think majority would not and God I like
this show has a crowd following it it
has an audience it sounds like if both
kids and adults you know and again on
Nickelodeon of all places and it is
challenging kids with these philosophies
and these teachings that they don't know
about and it's not just stuff basically
for kids I mean that this is advanced
stuff
and I love that it's doing that it knows
it has the influence so it doesn't dumb
down to the lowest common denominator
it's gonna challenge and it's gonna
teach you new things that is wonderful
and that's just a small aspect of this
episode you only get at the end but I
get I just I really want to give props
to that because I think that is so great
that they're doing that you see so many
things have become popular and they just
want to stay popular and reach a wider
crowd so they tried to dumb it down as
much as possible and they don't try new
things and they don't try to challenge
and this show does so I really really
love that um but let's talk about the
actual episode um the the king
surrenders these people go up hiding
underground it's taken over by the fire
nation which whoever's looking after it
I'm not sure if it was a king or what
but someone else appointed to ruling the
city and does not seem like a bad person
seems like a family guy has a nice wife
nice kids for the most part ooh there's
one that we'll go into in a moment here
but I really like again that it's not
just all the bad guys are bad all the
good guys are good you know that they're
mixing it up a bit though it does make
me again sir a question what are how do
some of these really good people get
into sort of ruling these nations in the
fire nation like I know it sounds weird
but what is the fire nation's politics
what is their philosophy it seems to be
on the weak we don't want the weak but
there seems to be good sympathetic
people in this group and they seem to
make it pretty high up you know one
ruling this new kingdom so I do question
it a touch but I think that's really
overanalyzing like really nitpicking um
but regardless so uh you got that going
on you got that these people need to be
they need to leave the city somehow
without getting caught so they come up
with this idea again this is where it
really pays to be a kid showcase you can
get away with this you're allowed to get
away with this this creative idea where
when they're trying to get in that these
octopuses octopi I don't know what the
term is um I don't even
that's what they are but these things
stick to sock and when they rip them off
they leave these dots and the guards
notice it and to get out of being caught
they say that he's infected and that
this is some sort disease that they made
up and they believe it and they've run
away uh so then they have to figure out
how to get these thousands of people out
and they took that one scene that you
know looks like it's just gonna be a
funny cute little scene ha ha just the
throw away gag and it comes back and
it's such a clever funny little idea
that allows thousands of people to
escape and so they all act like they've
been infected and that everyone else
that's healthy should stay away from
them and they're good you know they've
been exiled from the city cuz they're
diseased then it's so smart and I don't
think you could get away with that
necessarily in a live-action adult show
or movie you know they've see it as too
silly or that we're not creating worlds
where that's allowed in you know more
adult programming uh but you can get
away with it here and I again I really
love that balance I love that they say
hey we're gonna introduce some more
adult philosophies and ideas but also
hey we're still kid show we can really
create stuff we can be imaginative we
can have fun with this and again what
wonderful balance there um and we get an
coming across the king at the end and he
tells him about why he's surrendered and
that really in the sense he's just
waiting for the right moment to make his
move um which I get it's a philosophy it
doesn't necessarily mean it's right
there leaning towards its right um but
you don't know you see people get really
angry at him and a lot of people
probably would still stay angry at him
but Aang understands a little bit more
and give the trust to him you know he
trusts his friend so and again it's
introducing an idea that most kids even
most adults at least in America are not
familiar with so so you got that aspect
of the story and then you got you got
the character that as soon as I
mentioned just seeing her everybody's
like as soon as I
we brizola so we get more of her in this
episode and the right way she's a great
villain she's you know she's very
diabolical she's very cunning very
conniving I love these two I don't know
what they are they're advisers away it's
these twin old ladies who seem to be
totally in sync and that I love that
that's a great you know just question
who are they well what are they up to
I love this posse that she's getting now
the one is the the daughter of the ruler
Etta Omashu um who just wants to join an
army or do something evil because she's
bored I love that and you can see that
too you can see that she's bored you can
understand how she would come to that
route because she's a higher-up she's
practically a princess here and just
there's nothing to do it's expected for
her to be quiet and do nothing and she
has this incredible skill uh so that's
great she's very deadpan very quiet
sounds like her and Zuko K have like a
history they were hinting at stuff the
curious we'll see where that goes um and
then this other character who so doesn't
seem like a character that would be in
this posse you know I forget her name
she's free and adorable they give her
these great big eyes and she's really
flexible and always smiling and always
Abby she's hugging everybody and again
you do surco wait a minute this is she's
gonna be one of the bad guys so I be
shocked if she doesn't switch somewhere
down the line they make her way too
happy and way too likable um but she's
got this incredible talent too and at
this great fight at the end again
wonderful wonderful fight scene um and
and using the using the city to its
advantage with the the slides and with
the fact that's being taken over and
remodels if I gotta fight on that stuff
I using their powers and these these new
characters have new skills as really
wonderfully put together um so I like
that I like they're adding more villains
in which is always great uh and there um
and that you know the one thing I'm
realizing there's only one character I
don't care for you're not gonna believe
who it is
and I don't hate the character it's not
like you know a terrible creation or
anything it's just so forgettable I
don't care for Momo I think he is just
there's no personality to him the
Buffalo has more personality yeah I'm
watching him interact with this baby I'm
just like I I don't know what this means
I don't know if it's like oh it's gonna
happen it's like he just sort has this
blank face and eat stuff so I that's the
one character I don't know if they're
gonna do more with him but they
definitely haven't done anything yet um
so yeah again it's not like you know
kill Bob oh I'm not like that but it is
the one character that just sort of
seems like you know dead weight you know
sense you everyone to I he'll fly and
grab something but you know it seems
more like a video game
sidekick than an actual developed
character even if it is just an animal
you know I'm from Cowboy Bebop I thought
I had a lot more personality than this
thing so oh and maybe it gets better
maybe we'll go into Momo's backstory who
knows um so yeah this is another really
good strong episode oh yeah one last
thing I will comment on I was realizing
watching its episode and maybe it'll
grow on me I don't know I do like this
Azula character I like how evil she is
uh I don't know what turned the
gymnastic girl the one that was in the
circus what turned her over with like
you know the fire on the NED and the
animals and stuff and she just says the
universe seemed to point me into your
direction it's is it that she clearly
sees that Azula is threatening her or
did she just sort of see it as a sign
that she really thinks the universe kind
of directed her it's a I don't know it's
it was very odd obviously she had a
little twinge when Zula said she was
gonna see the show so it maybe it's that
Azula was make it obvious like I won't
kill you but bad things will happen if
you do not come with me
you know without actually saying that I
actually speak a lot of the words again
just having a ball can't wait to see the
next one I'll see you at that one